in our community coming together once  again to help out a person with a big  wish today finley customs and the  make-a-wish foundation presented a newly  refurbished car to gustavo a 19 year old  leukemia patient who wanted nothing more  than to have this 91 gmc sierra redone  well today he got to see the finished  product  when i first saw it i couldn't i  couldn't believe it  it's exactly how i wanted it a nice  original look on it but just  completely new and  um they did exactly that  i'm very i'm very proud of the truck i  like it and it's how i want it so i'm  very happy for it  looks really clean gustavo's battled  leukemia now for two years he undergoes  chemotherapy every week he says he's  almost finished with that treatment and  he remains optimistic and is forever  grateful to make a wish and finley  customs for making this ride look so  sleek  i think you could see the smile  inside the mask